president Trump won the New Hampshire
primary by a considerable margin it
wasn't a complete and total blowout it
wasn't you know 90 to 10 or something
but this is now effectively a two-person
race and he's very happy about it and he
gives a victory speech today I have to
tell you it was very interesting because
I said wow what a great Victory but then
somebody ran up to the stage all dressed
up
nicely when it was at 700 but now I just
walked up and it said
14 and you know we have to do what's
good for our party and she was up and I
said wow she's doing uh like a speech
like she won she didn't win she lost and
you know Trump turning up the attacks
just a little bit on Nikki Haley notice
these by Trump standards are not vicious
attacks at all